à
jusqu'à
photo dans l'ariège à l'âge de 10 ans ce
sont vos frères qui l'ont montré à faire
de la musique sont montrés à jouer de la
batterie comment ça s'est passé
c'est avec eux que j'ai commencé à faire
la musique et je dirais je prendrai un
crédit d'heures après on a joué parce
qu'ils sont pas cap
fillon jamais été vraiment incapable de
jouer de la batterie en fait c'est que
ce soit il y en a qui jouent de la
guitare
l'eau de la base moi je suis la plus
jeune de la famille puis ça prenait une
batterie puis j'avais un cousin 15 jouer
mes parents ont accepté de m'acheter une
batterie puis j'ai oui j'ai vraiment
j'ai vraiment appris la musique avec le
braquer la lumière
[Musique]
la famille a toujours et parents
toujours écouté beaucoup de musique donc
on est une famille qui est qui a baigné
là-dedans vraiment besoin d'eux
ou venez d'un petit village d'environ
500 habitants saint-françois de
lotbinière
comment vous avez fait ce choix de
consacrer votre vie à la musique est
partie et vous rendre à maureilhan pour
faire ça ça a été mon plan un nom je
suis parti à jonquière pour faire arts
et technologie des médias au programme
hausse de très très bien l'art des
caméras moi c'était vraiment atm les
plateaux de tournage et tout ça à la
sortie du cégep
quand j'ai eu mon diplôme en télé c'est
la première fois j'ai passé un test
technique pour travailler je nommerai
pas où mais et j'ai passé mon test c'est
la première fois dans toute ma vie où
j'ai que je pauchet un test ça s'appelle
un acte manqué mais je pense que oui je
pense que c'est estelle halal d'un
heureux hasard si on veut mais ça m'a
permis à ce moment-là de remettre en
question si on veut de remettre la
musique en question de ramener sont
plutôt en avant plan
[Musique]
pour vous quelle femme vous ont inspiré
à faire de la musique lorsque vous étiez
déjà noyé hier france d'amour
ouais ouais j'ai écouté beaucoup
beaucoup ses albums j'ai mangé mais son
côté très époque
guitare électrique du musashi guitare un
peu un peu grâce à eux si on veut un
mystère électrique entre j'avais
militants acoustique mais le switch à
l'électrique le soutien je veux du jeu
du pouvoir
mais ouais saviez un peu d'elle ensuite
il ya eu des artistes un peu plus loin
de 6 mai l'epide gervais
[Musique]
je me souviens de plans des objectifs et
gravissez ça on dirait que je l'ait
encore quand je monte sur scène je
repense à ça quand je me sens intimidée
ou non ça ne me prends ta place et pense
un petit peu à ses modèles poursuivi
celle à la maison qui vous connaissent
pas votre musique c'est faux ça
ressemble parfois du radiohead parce que
ça peut être un spectacle ça peut
brasser mais avec des lignes de basse à
s'est accentuée
et vous votre vous écrit comment vous
l'avouer j'avais beaucoup plus rock que
faut premièrement
[Musique]
et en fait je réalise que quand même un
écart entre le sont mes albums
est ce que je présente cinq ans
je monte sur une scène quand je vois ma
guitare électrique matin puis il ya mon
batteur qui est le symptôme d'un côté
tout ça les y ait quelque chose de il ya
le côté intime qui va ressortir le côté
qu'on retrouve sur les albums il y avait
un côté france d'amour sur saint aubin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trois albums plus tard vous vous
retrouvez nommé dans la prestigieuse
catégorie auteur compositeur au gala de
l'adisq et c'est une catégorie qui
longtemps a été réservé entre guillemets
aux hommes de voir que cette année il ya
des femmes qui prennent leur place et
qui sont là qu'est ce que cela vous fait
et c'est drôle facile et des
statistiques sont sortis il ya pas
longtemps je tombe et là tu subis je
pense qu'on est c'est la deuxième année
cette année et pau d'affilée le mais
c'est la deuxième année dans toute
l'histoire de l'adisq où il ya trois
femmes en nomination dans la catégorie
auteur compositeur
des fois il y en avait pas il ya des
années où il y avait pas de femmes en
nomination est assez parlé beaucoup
l'année dernière surtout dans l'émoi
dans les années passées et là on voit
des résultats concrets salomé leclerc
merci beaucoup merci
nuits sont longues à marcher dans l'âme
soeur
allo